[Musique]
non
l'intérieur
[Musique]
m
à
tha
[Musique]
bonjour je suis venu j'ai une passion
dans la vie c'est l'âge et je vais tout
faire pour que la communauté
bonjour je suis des mineurs
je partage la même passion
là j'ai fait n'importe quelle fille
mais la nôtre
alors qu'est ce que c'est travailler
récupérant 4 odland élabore un
échauffement jeudi pour s'amuser
les landes
[Musique]
nous allons et tous les dimanches matins
travaillés ans
dans une ambiance
non
et n'ayez pas peur ne provient pas du
carrousel en avoir écarté ribes à léo
alive chantier
[Musique]
tout le monde quoi faire
à
[Musique]
g
la musique est ce que vous êtes en train
de faire et venez vite avec nous c'est
très important comme vous assure que
michaud devrait surtout pour éviter une
nationale
[Musique]
voilà
tu là
et autour
là
[Musique]
j'en
changer
[Musique]
m
est ce que vous vous êtes bien chauffé
j'espère que tout le monde l'a fait
c'est très très important étant donné
qu'on va démarrer tous les cours par cet
échauffement qui est une super
préparation aux exercices qui vont
suivre alors en l'occurrence sur les
exercices au sol donc voilà c'est bien
comme nous du jour vous copier tout ce
que vous vivez
alors en exercice souplesse du dos
attention parce qu'elle établit
néanmoins stylisme paraît donc toujours
toujours toujours
musclé et apprendre à tenir alors on va
descendre intéressant à voir aux gens
qui règne des pirouettes et des cuistots
dur
ensuite on va faire avec des pieds
réflexe après les crises politiques et
noir
moi j'en pensais
elle
achat des séries mais vraiment sur les
gens super
deuxième mouvement et à nous manquer
dans la continuité de
véronique donc les mêmes toujours son
dos on s'étire salomon allons bien ses
jambes et on refuse du genou droit
pas trop repliés juste un petit regard
viendront on ne livre pas si on allonge
s'imagine ici dans le creux des reins
qui vient justement pas être mais qu'il
reste
froid et films à visée vous pousse de 6
à m'amuser donc sur les rails les maux
de l'afrique
la pression et vous faites avec un choix
entre les deux chambres la pensée façon
on va dans le troisième mouvement j'ai
travaillé l'intérieur des cuisses alors
une jambe au sol tendu le dos toujours
plus à vrai dire un pied droit était il
va falloir sont donnés d'accous et sans
bouger dans le buste bleu de la pointe
du pied tape et a fait de l'autre côté
voulez vraiment vous allez sentir sous
la pluie
normalement vous faire travailler
l'intérieur des cuisses l'extérieur
le père toujours le temps du fond du
temple alors ça va faire ça et on va le
faire en syrie après contre affaires
dans lesquelles vous allez sentir proche
de 11 en détail c'est ça c'est pas beau
ça
tiré de faire des muscles ont l'eau
[Musique]
maintenant on ramène sa jambe droite à
l'extérieur de sa jambe gauche
je prends ça suffit donc de plus près
possible ça dure en droit de son but
la france et on lève partie levé par
symantec jantes la jambe gauche de
manquer ce stade à ce moment là tous
attendent en silicone et qu'on est là
jean haas après c'est bien son dos sur
le biais de la taille circhetta en
avance et de cette manière on l'a
beaucoup une facilité pour le vêlage à
la ligue dont ses débuts parce qu'il est
simple la même chose de l'autre
attention bobo c'est essentiel et très
incertaine montrez vous tirez vous
allongez commencer
m
[Musique]
voilà maintenant que vous passiez avec
nous et sans se répéter
aller zieuter toute votre énergie royal
a trouvé en cinq minutes les bleus
allaient d'énergie dans le rue qu'est ce
qu'on fait allez-y
[Musique]
oui
non
[Musique]
tard
là est tiré
cap aux échanges et moi deuxième plongée
m
moi
taulier chant capable
[Musique]
j'sais pas
rien de plus
un jeu
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
kaboul
m
[Musique]
oh
à
à poitiers
non
[Musique]
enfin
voir
c'est pas tout
non
pas là
[Musique]
enfin
quoi
[Musique]
c'est blanc
et
parodie
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas
bah 4chan spam
à
jean
[Musique]
et
m
les verts
le bon plan
attention
moi
[Musique]
man qu'il a changé d'âme
-
oui
jamais
on attaque la gueule
ça va vous sembler dessine en fait que
des fans les portes on a fait des
mouvements qui vont vous faire
travailler tout le corps des chevilles
aux du coup c'est le cas de le dire mais
d'une façon assez facile et qui pour
vous à vous semblez le bout du monde
alors on y va
suivez bien tous debout monter bientôt
tendez les cuisses tendait les genoux et
ouvrez un petit peu les pieds et on va
faire des soupes là son descendant au
maximum sans savoir à lever les talons
pour les christie russie derrière et les
menus et des bustes ce but toujours le
maintenir bien bien droit voilà alors là
vous fait travailler et maintenant du
plié on va danser genoux les cuisses et
on va remonter comme ça mais il faut que
terriblement tant rêver les cuisses sont
vous les fait partir vous allez être
compétitif alors résister maintenant va
s'offrir de très jolies épaules avec les
mouvements suivants montrent une épaule
l'épaule droite à son oreille seulement
les pôles rien
ce que les pauvres fait la même chose
avec l'épaule gauche
ensuite la même chose avec les deux
époux les quand on descend lebron a
l'impression laser sait combien de tomes
qui pèse sur les épaules
ensuite on fait la même chose en pliant
même chose et paul amplio et elle vous
sent bien sur ses talons et ensuite la
même chose avec ses 2 est pour très
important
seulement vous les épaules et quand les
gens ne les tue le bus à bouger et un
troisième exercice qui va terriblement
nous qu'à travailler le but est la
taille alors on ouvre tes pieds poussé
ici les bras devant sont tendues on va
pousser les pôles car dans la paix plus
possible pour édition de guti français
que veau d'or
elles ne doivent pas bouger la pointe
des anges reste soit enfin la même chose
avec une épaule au tir aux tirs ou
résiste ici et on avoue des plus dessin
en appel on pousse la hanche la douce
l'épaule ensuite on va les enchaîner la
très loin et les mains très loin là nous
impossible en gardant la tête comme ça
donc elle défend vous allez rater
on enchaîne avec des mouvements de
souplesse mais toujours en gardant ses
jambes
cette fois ci les tirs et allongée on
pilote le buste sur la droite on étire
ses deux reins en arias
ou son buste en avant sur le côté droit
quatre coups légers vers le bas mais pas
trop bas mais moi ce niveau là ensuite
on revient droite la même chose à gauche
on étire ont toujours c'est le bras
serait très loin derrière soi et la même
chose en avant est ici attention de rien
un problème de poids du beurre faut pas
pousser vos fesses en arrière fond
contre elle devait ramener le plus
possible droit faudra votre poids du
corps est ce qu'on a devant nous et on
pousse en avant alors à droite à gauche
et en hockey maintenant pas question de
vous relâcher ou de vous décourager des
buts mais ces mouvements sont absolument
pour vous alors avec nous dans tous les
enchaînements pendant cinq minutes
allez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
car
attirer
[Musique]
ok
m
[Musique]
les poules alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça
et toi
[Musique]
tous dans la souplesse et c'est le buste
bien droit et souffre ne déconnez pas
les talents voilà maintenant tirer bien
tirait bien sur le coup
allons je récuse voilà ça c'est parfait
soupe source
et alors j'ai monté mon rythme n'était
pas les épaules voilà
voilà ça s'est très très bien maintenant
remonter books anglais un tracteur et
allonger vos bras allonger les délais
pourraient tirer sur vos droits on fait
le plus en phase iib poser pour le
safari terry toulouse voilà rester
deviendront elles ne vous laissez pas
tomber
regardez-vous ondes et les genoux
surtout voir là c'était très bien à
surmonter vous tendez les bras qu'à côté
4 changé d'épaulés 4
[Musique]
hu
pour alors maintenant c'est le moment de
folie
c'est le moment où on se défoule on y va
à fond c'est le jogging aller avec la
musique on y va
[Musique]
rires
rapport
[Musique]
en revanche m
à quelle place
[Musique]
alors
les enfants ont sauvé la vie voilà
respirer j'avais tant la relaxation
lundi
respirez calmement 1
13-3
la chaîne
changer et
la chef
[Musique]
et sans les épaules jeu
machu la pac
le col
et doucement
doucement
l'enseigné
here comes en arrêt
la sportive la musique pas sa bague
il a taillé blum
et on relâche la tête
[Musique]
oh
rires et sans les prendre
[Musique]
la chine
mireille
doucement
lâchait sur le coup de bec
[Musique]
les machines
les récents des cas ça donne quoi
mais non
et
et appuyez sur le tour
[Musique]
bravo aux entraîneurs avaient combattu
re ne vous inquiétez pas sûr puisque
vous êtes plein de questions à me poser
écrivez nous voilà l'unique arbre aux
équidés nous vous attendons volée que
nous répondrons à toutes sans exception
la dimanche au revoir vivante au revoir
[Musique]